okay let's get into audience questions
for the week a lot of very
sort of similar it's clear what the
audience is thinking about and i
understand why
first question is david what do we do if
donald trump refuses to accept
election results so there's two
different ways that accept can be
interpreted
he refuses to accept them in that he
claims it was rigged
but he's still leaving or he refuses to
accept it and that he's going to try to
stay
in the white house now i wanna again
restate
most likely we don't have to do anything
because
donald trump if he loses in november
come january twenty first
will simply not be the president he's
just not the president anymore
now for me the biggest concern is trump
rigging the election and winning
i think that's a bigger concern than him
not accepting the results but let's play
it out
um we see trump undermine democracy
he jokes about staying in power a long
time he says to chris wallace on sunday
this past sunday
he's not yet ready to commit to
accepting the results so now there are
articles being published about
what what we what we would have to do if
that was the case
and most of them say well we would have
to mobilize
listen you and i aren't removing donald
trump it's ultimately going to depend on
the systems
that we have so from a practical
standpoint the most likely scenario is
trump is going to leave
because on january 21st he would not be
president anymore if he loses the
november election
and there would be a new president and
at that point he would be trespassing in
the oval office and he would be escorted
out
but where i believe our efforts are
better spent because we ultimately can't
control that and i
i do trust that he will will be removed
if he physically tried to stay
what we can do is it's only july
so we're better off doing what we can do
to prevent vote rigging
making sure people aren't dropped from
voter rolls
and fighting that in court as has been
done expanding absentee ballot access i
just filled out my absentee ballot
application
this week and plan to vote by mail all
of that stuff because
with all of these things and this is
going to come up again later in this
segment
prevention is cheaper than the cure if
trump
tries to stay in office i i really don't
know how he gets
away with it he won't be president
anymore somebody else will be
sworn in and eventually he's going to be
removed and he's not going to be the
president
am i that naive right i mean it's like
are there people listening who really
think that that's naive
that even something like that like if
biden wins
and he shows up ready for work with his
lunchbox and everything
and trump's there and he says i'm not
leaving that that's going to be allowed
to happen
i don't believe that that's going to be
allowed to happen if you believe i'm
wrong
i want to hear what the path would be
and i understand the fear which is
trump has flouted every norm he's
you know constitutional violations
emoluments
all of this different stuff i get it i
still don't think that he is going to be
able to stay
i actually think that trump the
narcissist
if he loses and this is a big if and we
don't want to put the cart before the
horse and we've got a vote and all of
that that i've been saying
i think if trump loses his narcissism
will force him to essentially say
i didn't want it anyway to essentially
make it undesirable when when you have
an extreme narcissist
and you take away from them something
that they want
what they typically do is they say i
didn't really want it or i don't want it
anymore
or it's not worth that much anymore let
someone else have it i'll make more
money in real estate
etc so that is more likely to me if
trump loses to basically say
i'm out you know i'm better off going
back to real estate good luck with joe
biden or whatever
than trying to stay in power because
that's often how the narcissist works
now
the authoritarian narcissist may try to
stay in power
and trump certainly has no shortage of
authoritarian tendencies
but i believe if he loses he will leave
let's focus on preventing the
election from being rigged against biden
there we can do something
one of our sponsors today is cuts
clothing
offering the most high quality men's
t-shirts you'll be able to find
anywhere and they are giving you 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c-u-t-s solid color
t-shirts are a critical part of
any wardrobe so it could not be more
important to have t-shirts that you
actually love wearing
and cuts clothing has totally changed
everything i believed i knew about
t-shirts
they've put a ton of thought and
research into the comfort and the
durability of the shirts that they make
all of my cuts t-shirts fit me perfectly
they're not itchy they don't shrink or
fade or
stretch out over time which was the case
with a lot of my pre-cuts t-shirts they
are seriously the most comfortable
t-shirts i've owned
if you're watching on youtube right now
i am wearing the
crew neck split hem black shirt
excellent soft fits perfectly check out
everything they have
they've got polo shirts it's unlike any
polo shirt you've ever worn
as soon as you first put on a shirt from
cuts clothing
you'll be able to tell the difference
between this and other shirts you've
owned in the past
it's really the only t-shirt worth
buying and you'll get fifteen percent
off
when you go to davidpakman.com slash
cuts that's davidpakman.com
c-u-t-s